[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die cdu macht also offenbar
ernst mit dem neuanfang zum dritten mal
in nur drei jahren alles auf null und
dann keine nullen mehr vorne das ist das
rezept der cdu ja immer noch neue aber
schon verbrauchte führungsspitze wird
sich ums jahresende herum neuen wahlen
stellen müssen und vorher sollen die 300
+ kreisvorsitzenden der cdu aus allen
bundesländern außer bayern zu was und
sowie des neuanfangs gehört werden als
anwälte der basis damit ist natürlich
noch keine machtfrage entschieden aber
immerhin mal ein weg dorthin beschrieben
wenn die hitze über die suche nach neuem
kurs für eine neue kommandobrücke
endziel rückkehr an die macht in vier
jahren
wenn eine sitzung der cdu zu ende ist
und eine pressekonferenz angekündigt
warten die medien vor allem auf die die
keine pressekonferenz geben
trauben wie diese symbolisieren ein
politik mensch ist stehen geblieben es
besteht die hoffnung dass sich jemand
weniger bedeckt gibt und erzählt was
wirklich in der sitzung passiert ist
heute blieb das relativ erfolglos treppe
runter und weckt die meisten stürmen
ohne ein wort davon andere schütteln
wenigstens noch den kopf oder versuchen
sich in ihrer eigenen traube unsichtbar
zu machen
bleibt also erstmal nur der
generalsekretär der erklärt wie die cdu
möglicherweise einen neuen chef eine
neue chefin finden will es braucht in
zukunft mehr mitgliederbeteiligung
deswegen haben wir uns entschieden am 30
oktober zu einer konferenz der
kreisvorsitzenden
einzuladen auf dieser konferenz der
soll über die frage der
mitgliederbeteiligung von mehr
mitgliederbeteiligung diskutiert werden
hat plötzlich bei der cdu die basis das
wort in einer partei die bislang alle
ihre vorsitzenden auf parteitagen
bestimmt hat
bei denen es zuletzt knapp geworden ist
in kampfabstimmungen die man nun schon
mehr basis die meinungen gehen darüber
in der cdu weit auseinander aber die
forderung kommt immer hörbarer aus dem
osten der partei und von den jüngeren
das ist auch nicht eine last dass die
parteibasis eingebunden wird sondern aus
meiner sicht eine selbstverständlichkeit
es ist eine voraussetzung dafür dass das
auch gut wird in den nächsten jahren ob
man das mit einem mitgliederentscheid
oder auf eine andere art und weise macht
wird man sehen das ist ja für uns alle
so wenn wir irgendwo selber mitgewirkt
haben sei es beim essen sei es beim
aufbau eines ikea möbelstücks dann geht
es uns danach viel besser wir haben die
ganz andere verbindung damit deswegen
brauchen wir stärkere mitmach elemente
auch in unserer partei diese mitmach
elemente kosten zeit die nächsten wahlen
kommen bald das macht druck der
generalsekretär kündigt an entscheiden
werden die parteioberen drei tage nach
den kreisvorsitzenden über die basis
beteiligung wie sie diese ganz konkret
aus in welchem rahmen soll die
stattfinden und im lichte dieser
entscheidung soll dann auch festgelegt
werden wann der bundesparteitag zusammen
kommt noch ist alles offen wie wann wer
auf armin laschet nachfolgen könnte der
gibt heute unsichtbar er hatte seiner
partei abgerungen heute nicht vor jedem
mikrofon stehen zu bleiben und sich dort
weiter zu zerfleischen
mal gucken wie lange dieser anschein des
friedens wert
als der kandidat armin laschet drei
wochen vor der wahl erkannte dass seine
persönliche anziehungskraft allein den
sieg nicht bringen wird hat er seiner
kampagne noch schnell ein zukunftsteam
als unterbau verpasst das neue und
jungen und bunter aussah als sich die
union zuvor präsentiert hatte da fiel
eine politikerin auf die bundesweit
fielen noch nicht begegnet war silvia
bremer rechtsanwältin aus niedersachsen
vor gerade mal vier jahren erstmals und
direkt in den bundestag gewählt stieg
dort quasi aus dem stand zur vize
vorsitzenden der partei auf als
nachfolgerin von ursula von der sie hat
ihren wahlkreis cloppenburg vechta
wieder direkt gewonnen bestes
cdu-ergebnis im ganzen land aber auch
sie musste dabei mehr als acht prozent
federn lassen guten abend frau bringen
guten abend ich lebe heute wurde von
ihrer partei im verfahren beschlossen
aber noch kein inhaltlicher neuanfang
wie muss der nach ihrer ansicht auswegen
also zunächst mal ist für uns
entscheidend dass wir in die erneuerung
gehen und heute haben wir den
startschuss für die zukunft gelegt aber
das kann nicht nur mit einem kopf
passieren an sehr am ende sind wir dann
wieder da wo wir gestartet sind sondern
köpfe haben immer was mit inhalt zu tun
und für uns ist wichtig dass wir das
verbinden und dann auch zu einer
inhaltlichen diskussion kommen und wie
sollte diese diskussion anders sein als
die diskussion bisher
wir haben einfach seit dem wechsel auf
eine gerät kramp karrenbauer und dann
auch auf armin laschet die korona phase
dazwischen gehabt und wir haben keinen
inhaltlichen parteitag führen können wir
haben auch vor allen dingen die
ergebnisse der strukturen
satzungskommission überhaupt nicht in
die tat umsetzen können und ich glaube
da ist einiges liegen geblieben was wir
aufarbeiten wollen machen sie doch mal
uns eine vorstellung mit ein paar
konkreten vorschlägen was muss bei der
cdu auftauchen was bisher verdeckt war
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass wir
wieder zur geschlossenheit zurückkommen
müssen und viele in der partei aber auch
drumherum haben es einfach sagt diesen
streit dieser innerparteiliche zwist und
auch das ego vieler einzelner insofern
glaube ich erstmal geschlossenheit und
ein team für die zukunft aufzustellen
und neuen vorstand zu wählen und
deswegen ist es richtig nicht nur über
den vorsitzenden zu sprechen sondern den
ganzen bundesvorstand neu zu wählen als
erstes und als zweites geht es dann
darum auch eine breite inhaltliche
diskussion zu führen über strukturen bei
der kanzlerkandidatur haben wir gesehen
was wir noch nicht für strukturen haben
und auch bei der beteiligung von frauen
und das dritte geht dann wirklich um
unsere inhalte in der cdu unter brauchen
wir eine breite diskussion und vor allen
dingen auch wieder die breite der partei
sichtbar von unseren flügeln von unseren
vereinigung hin zu einer position welche
welcher flügel welcher aspekt der cdu
ist denn jetzt unter die räder gekommen
in der mischung aus laschet und krone
wir haben in der letzten zeit
tatsächlich vor allen dingen über
personen gesprochen und nicht mehr über
inhalte und unsere mitglieder auch vor
ort die sagen wir ja sie ja warum bin
ich denn in der partei und das müssen
sie beantworten können an jeder an ihrer
stelle und in jeder sekunde im grunde
aus überzeugung sagen zu können ich bin
in der cdu weil und das ist glaube ich
unsere aufgabe das wieder transparenter
mit allen wirklich wieder bis an die
basis und von der basis bis an die
spitze zu transportieren sie merken
schon dass ich hier zeit beinahe drei
minuten versuche bei ihnen jetzt irgend
eine inhaltliche position mal raus zu
hören und sie laufen wir immer wieder
davon wenn eine hoffnungsträgerin wie
sie nicht zur sache und klartext spricht
wer soll es denn dann machen es
lieber wir haben viele inhalt und da
können wir unsere große familien
thematik nehmen da können wir das thema
schulden union nehmen und da können wir
vor allen dingen auch
sicherheitspolitische aspekte nehmen es
wir sind doch so breit auch in der
partei unter aber sie beschreiben immer
nur themen und keine positionen
interessant wäre doch jetzt mal zu sagen
sie sagen zum beispiel familienpolitisch
ist dies und das falsch gelaufen wir
müssen jetzt mal dort festlegen oder
schulden union darf es nicht geben die
schwarze null ist unverhandelbar mit uns
so etwas und ich höre immer nur zaghafte
schule beschreiben von themenkomplexen
warum traut sich in dieser situation
jemand wie sie nicht bei inhaltlich
position zu beziehen
wir haben ganz ganz verschiedene themen
wir können gerne ein einzelnes
ansprechen ein sind bei mir natürlich
auch innerhalb der partei die frauen die
wir wieder nach vorne bringen wollen
aber eins ist eben schulden union haben
sie gerade angesprochen das lehnen wir
ab beim thema familie ist uns wichtig
die familie in den mittelpunkt zu
stellen keine ideologie links oder
rechts sondern wirklich daran aber das
habe ich in ihrem wahlkampf alles
dauernd gehört und geld das haben wir in
ihrem wahlkampf andauernd gehört und was
ist daran jetzt neu wenn sie es wieder
sagen wir wollen das in die vereinigung
tragen wir müssen auch mal wieder streit
positionen ausfechten wie zum beispiel
die frage eines eines freiwilligen
jahres wollen wir das verpflichtend oder
wollen wir das nicht ich glaube dass wir
große grundsätzliche diskussionen wie
zum beispiel den atomausstieg der am
ende ziemlich schnell beschlossen wurde
aber in der partei nicht diskutiert
werden konnte vielmehr wieder in der
partei diskutieren und ich glaube das
ist unsere aufgabe in zukunft wieder
grundsätzliche fragen und nicht nur die
fragen des alltäglichen geschäft sondern
wirklich auch grundsätzliche fragen zu
diskutieren
im moment weil sie das mehrfach
angesprochen haben mit der rolle der
frauen in der partei im moment sind
sozusagen favoriten für den neuen
vorsitz ausschließlich männer darf das
so bleiben
also ich wünsche mir und werde alles
daran setzen dass frauen in dieser
partei eine größere rolle wieder spielen
und da geht es am ende nicht nur um den
kopf der ganz vorne steht sondern um das
team was drum herum steht und da kann es
nicht sein dass hier und da mal unter
zehn zwei frauen stehen sondern das
müssen einfach mehr sein und da werde
ich alles daran setzen gemeinsam mit
vielen weiteren eine haben wir kennen
gelernt einen schönen guten abend und
dankeschön
gerne
und das interview haben wir wegen der
unsicheren verbindung nach cloppenburg
vorhin aufgezeichnet in einer anderen
partei die ihr wahlergebnis auch noch
verdauen muss hat der vorsitzende keine
alternative zum rückzug mehr gesehen der
afg abgeordnete und vorsitzende mountain
hat nach langem schlingerkurs gegenüber
dem völkisch nationalen flügel zuletzt
auf konfrontation gesetzt und inzwischen
verloren weil die afg bei der
bundestagswahl stramm rechts erfolge
eingefahren hat vor allem im osten der
republik nun zog leuten die konsequenz
thomas reichert berichtet
und das politische ende des jörg merten
hat sich angekündigt etwa am tag nach
der wahl also sich auf offener bühne mit
den kfd spitzenkandidaten über das
wahlergebnis stritt wir mögen da
wirklich eine differenz haben wenn der
in der beurteilung ich muss ihn auch
ganz klar sagen dass ich das ergebnis
bin ich und uns auch nicht schlecht
reden lassen lasse nun also der rückzug
vom spitzenamt in einer mail an die fdp
mitglieder schreibt er ich habe mich
nach sehr sorgsam um den vielen
intensiven gesprächen insbesondere auch
mit meiner familie herangereift
überlegungen entschlossen auf diesem
parteitag nicht für eine weitere
amtszeit als bundessprecher zu
kandidieren heute zieht damit die
konsequenz daraus dass er in einer
radikalisierten afd zunehmend isoliert
und ohne mehrheit da steht hier
rechtsextreme teil innerhalb der ard
wird immer stärker leuten hat es nicht
geschafft denen einhalt zu gebieten
gleichzeitig kann er in westdeutschland
auch keine erfolge verzeichnen insofern
ist der rückzug sei folgerichtig wollten
hat sich für seinen eigenen aufstieg
lange mit den extrem rechten seiner
partei verbündet erst in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren wandte er sich gegen
sie etwa auf dem parteitag in kalkar und
darf so keinesfalls weiter gehen
entweder wir kriegen hier die kurve und
zwar sehr entschlossen und sehr bald
oder wir werden da als parteien keine
sehr naher zukunft die ganz ganz schwere
see geraten und gegebenenfalls scheitern
und damals wie heute ging es um die
ausrichtung der partei um morgens
versucht die afg als etwas weniger
radikal erscheinen zu lassen wie bei j
dieser weg ist ein irrweg dieser weg ist
falsch so spalt ist die partei heute ist
so etwas wie der zauberlehrling der afg
die geister die er rief wurde er nicht
mehr los nun gibt er sich geschlagen und
seine intimfeinde jubeln rechtsaußen
andreas kalbitz schreibt auf twitter
über den rückzug gute entscheidung
leuten hatte ihn rauswerfen kalbitz aus
der afg durchgesetzt auch vom ko
vorsitzenden mit dem er über kreuz liegt
gibt es heute nur einen kühlen dank
es schafft jetzt klarheit für uns vor
dem bundesparteitag ist ein fairer
schritt und damit wissen natürlich auch
alle parteimitglieder und auch die
delegierten woran sie sind nun geht es
um die nachfolge nrw landeschef rüdiger
lucassen wäre ein kandidat aus dem
westen der auch mal mit radikalen kann
aber er zögert noch den landesverband
nrw jetzt zu verlassen das thema ein
büro sie gleich auf dem weg der
konsolidierung das will ich zur zeit
noch nicht aber bis mitte dezember ist
noch viel zeit und ich schließe es für
mich nicht aus mario mieruch wurde 2017
für die afc in den bundestag gewählt
verließ die fraktion weil sie zu weit
nach rechts rückte die nachricht heute
sieht das teil einer langen entwicklung
wird die partei wird den den den weg in
die radikalisierung
weitergehen so wie sie das ja halt eben
die ganze zeit schon macht und mit
leuten ist dann jetzt quasi auch das
letzte feigenblatt der bürgerlichen
letzten endes dann weg wollten selbst
ließ heute offen aber am ende auch die
afg verlässt nur soviel er wünscht sich
für seine nachfolge eine besonnene wahl
und vernünftige vorstandsmitglieder
nachrichten nun von bundes oder gasen
spd grüne und fdp haben in weiteren
sondierungsgesprächen über die bildung
einer möglichen ersten ampelkoalition
auf bundesebene beraten erst morgen
mittag wollen sich die unterhändler
öffentlich äußern weitere treffen sind
für morgen und freitag angesetzt wird
wochen donnerstag beraten die
generalsekretäre über die bekannten
streitpunkte in der steuer und
finanzpolitik sowie beim klimaschutz
ziel ist eine zwischenbilanz bis zum
ende der woche als basis für eine
entscheidung über
koalitionsverhandlungen
die gesundheitsminister von bund und
ländern haben sich nicht auf eine
bundesweite corona testpflicht für
beschäftigte mit kundenkontakten
verständigen können jedes bundesland
soll das nun selbst entscheiden das
bundesgesundheitsministerium verteidigte
erneut das ende der kostenlosen corona
tests jeder könne sich kostenlos impfen
lassen zahlen für die tests müssen nun
alle kostenfrei bleiben sie für kinder
unter 12 jahren und für unter 18-jährige
bis jahresende so auch für schwangere in
den ersten drei monaten ihrer
schwangerschaft und wenn medizinische
gründe eine impfung verhindern viele
universitäten beginnen das
wintersemester wieder mit
präsenzveranstaltungen nach drei corona
online semestern kamen wie hier in köln
wieder tausende studierende zusammen zum
teil an ungewöhnlichen orten aber unter
einhaltung der 3g regeln die hochschulen
haben check-in systeme installiert um
stichprobenartig kontrollen zu
ermöglichen
über die konkrete umsetzung entscheiden
jeweils die universitäten
tunesien hat eine neue regierung drei
monate nachdem präsident kay said die
frühere regierung entlassen hatte
verteidigte er heute überraschend ein
neues kabinett dem neuen frauen
angehören auch den posten des
regierungschefs übernimmt eine frau die
geologie professorin lmu denn will vor
allem gegen die korruption kämpfen das
letzte wort bei regierungsentscheidungen
hat aber weiterhin der präsident die
irakische regierung hat die festnahme
eines hochrangigen wie es terroristen
gemeldet der von den usa gesuchte mann
soll finanzchef des sogenannten
islamischen staates sein an der
parlamentswahl haben sich so wenig
iraker beteiligt wie noch nie seit dem
sturz von saddam hussein vor 18 jahren
nur rund 41 prozent der
stimmberechtigten stärkste kraft ist
ersten auszählungen zufolge die von den
schiitischen geistlichen als andere
angeführte bewegung die wahl war wegen
der anhaltenden krise im irak und
massenprotesten gegen die regierung
vorgezogen worden
in österreich wurde sebastian kurz heute
mit zarten 35 jahren schon zum zweiten
mal alt kanzler das erste mal verlor er
sein amt in der ubs-affäre es folgte
dann eine übergangsregierung ein neuer
wahlerfolg und eine neue koalition mit
den grünen und dann ein neuer skandal
diesmal mit kurz selbst im mittelpunkt
im blieb nur der rücktritt jedenfalls
musste ein rücktritt ähnlicher vorgang
inszeniert werden der karikaturist der
süddeutschen zeitung sieht die hebel der
macht im schatten weiter beim parteichef
kurz auch wenn davor eingeführt sammer
kanzler spielen darf der bericht von
britta hilpert
ich gelobe damit ist alexander
schallenberg kanzler der diplomat
ex-außenminister sebastian kurz wenn
seine blitzkarriere verdankt der
sebastian kurz der hat in ihm einen
tollen statthalter und der grüne
koalitionspartner hat die untadelige
persönlichkeit die er verlangte ist die
krise damit vorbei die neuformierte
bundesregierung trägt nun eine große
verantwortung dafür dass das vertrauen
der bevölkerung in die politik wieder
hergestellt wird doch der mann der den
größten einfluss darauf hat ist heute
unsichtbar auf sebastian kurz kommt es
weiter an er steht in den kulissen und
zieht die fäden als parteichef und
fraktionsvorsitzender ich gehe davon aus
dass wir dann auch
in dieser funktion von sebastian kurz
eine gute zusammenarbeit haben denn die
grünen wollen unbedingt ihre projekte
durchbringen das landesweite ticket für
den öffentlichen nahverkehr
der einstieg in eine co2 bepreisung und
eine ökosoziale steuerreform für
österreich grüne lieblingsprojekte die
nun der neue kanzler umsetzen soll
deshalb schlugen die grünen dass es den
neuen kanzler nur im doppelpack gibt mit
dem alten
ich werde selbstverständlich mit
sebastian kurz zu eng zusammenarbeiten
alles andere wäre demokratiepolitisch
absurd
zudem halte ich die im raum stehenden
vorwürfe für falsch
zweimal hat sebastian kurz bundes waren
für die övp gewonnen dafür betont man
dieser tage immer wieder dankbarkeit
doch nun rumort es in der partei denn
wer weiß was da noch kommt in österreich
dauern solche verfahren schon mal zehn
jahre
und auch heute gab es wieder
enthüllungen neue jets in der presse
peinlich die einblicke in die wortwahl
und den politischen stil manche gehen
vorsichtig auf distanz
wenn strafrechtliche dimension und
vorhanden sind und was dran wäre dann
sind die konsequenzen ohne ihn hart zu
treffen da gibt es bei mir null pendant
in dem zusammenhang aber als partei hat
man auch an gewissen umgang zu
beurteilen gewissen stil immer
miteinander pflegt und so weiter da kann
man natürlich in chats auch gewisse
dinge zutage mit denen man aus meiner
sicht nichts anfangen kann
bei seinem rücktritt am samstag hat
sebastian kurz das wort entschuldigung
nicht in den mund genommen
er macht nur platz auf zeit so lässt er
durchblicken er ist nicht weg er will
bleiben irgendwie und damit bleibt die
krise
weltweit sind in den kommenden zehn
jahren eine million tier und
pflanzenarten vom aussterben bedroht
davor waren der welt biodiversitäts rad
und mahnt gegenstrategien an darüber
beraten in dieser woche 200
vertragsstaaten der un konvention für
die biologische vielfalt unter dem
vorsitz chinas in kunming ende april
soll ein neues rahmenabkommen stehen
deutsche ziele lauten mehr und besser
verwaltete schutzgebiete sowie eine
geringere natur verschmutzung etwa durch
plastikmüll
deutlich mehr tempo beim klimaschutz
verlangen 69 deutsche unternehmen von
der neuen bundesregierung an der
initiative beteiligen sich unter anderem
die allianz bayer sap und thyssenkrupp
appelle für einen ehrgeizigeren ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien sind nicht neu
frank bethmann was konkret fordern die
unternehmen mehr vor allem verlangen sie
dass sich die deutsche politik stärker
für die ziele des pariser
klimaschutzabkommens einsetzung dass es
einen klaren fahrplan gibt wie genau
denn deutschland in den kommenden
jahrzehnten klimaneutral werden soll es
ist der ruf nach staatlichen
investitionen aber auch nach leitplanken
so die konzern initiative die sich in
der stiftung mit dem namen zwei grad
formiert hat klare vorgaben und die
schnell bereits bis 20.30 sollen so das
unternehmen das bündnis mindestens 70%
des steigenden deutschen stromverbrauchs
durch erneuerbare energien gedeckt
werden um das allerdings zu erreichen
müssten die windkraft und solar
kapazitäten verdreifacht werden manch
einem markt diese grüne offensive
überraschen doch ganz uneigennützig ist
sie nicht die unternehmer wollen
klarheit beispielsweise wird das
steuersystem klimafreundlich umgestellt
oder gibt es sonder
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten für
klimafreundliche investitionen
wichtige fragen für die gruppe die aus
69 unternehmen besteht und die
hierzulande eine millionen menschen
beschäftigt weltweit sogar fünf
millionen und die nach eigenen angaben
einen globalen umsatz von etwa einer
million euro erwirtschaftet
die beteiligten unternehmen kommen aus
allen relevanten schlüsselindustrien ihr
appell heute eindeutig für den
gewaltigen umbau der deutschen
wirtschaft braucht es einen
verlässlichen rahmen und zwar schnell
frank bethmann vielen dank der
diesjährige alfred nobel gedächtnispreis
für wirtschaftswissenschaften geht an
drei
arbeitsmarktforscher die in den usa
forschende ökonomen hätten die
empirische arbeit komplett neu gestaltet
so die begründung david card erhält die
hälfte des preisgeldes von knapp einer
million euro für seine empirischen
beiträge zur arbeitsmarkt ökonomie
joshua ist und guido im benz teilen sich
die andere hälfte für ihre
grundlagenforschung zur analyse von
kausal beziehungen
viele menschen in sachsen haben
lückenhafte kenntnisse über das
funktionieren von medien das ergibt eine
repräsentative studie zum
medienkompetenzen die sachsen als erstes
bundesland durchgeführt hat laut
sächsischer landeszentrale für
politische bildung sind rund 20 prozent
der sachsen der meinung medien sein
eigentum des staates
25 prozent glauben berichte müssten von
ministerien freigegeben werden und 40
prozent der über 65 jährigen sind
überzeugt medien hätten die aufgabe das
meinungsbild der bevölkerung zu
beeinflussen
in köln läuft gerade die größte
nahrungsmittel beste der welt die anuga
und in diesem jahr scheint wahr zu
werden worüber seit vielen jahren
geforscht geredet und geschrieben wird
fleisch aus der retorte wohlgemerkt
keine auf gewürzten tofu welchen sondern
wirkliches
biologisch erzeugtes fleisch nur ohne
ein tier zu töten die wissenschaft hat
enträtselt wie die natur fleisch erzeugt
und macht es ihr nach investoren haben
milliarden in diese entwicklung gesteckt
und demnächst landet sie auf unseren
tellern darf
diese industrie dominik müller sl über
den stand der dinge
es ist ein kleiner hafen für jeden der
ausgewählten probanden heute auf der
lebensmittelmesse anuga in köln aber
vielleicht ein großer wenn es darum geht
wie künftig fleisch produziert wird
es schmeckt sehr gut im mund fühlte sich
noch ein bisschen körnig an aber es
schmeckt zu beginn war noch etwas stark
dass erbsen oder tschuldigung dass
pflanzen protein schmeckbar über die
zeit hinweg hat er seinen guten lange
nach geschmack wie fleisch wie
fleischbällchen hat mir sehr gut
gefallen zu einem teil bestehen die
bällchen aus soja zum anderen teil aber
aus einer lösung hühnchen fettzellen die
im labor in einem bioreaktor hergestellt
wurde hühnchenfleisch also für das kein
einziges huhn sterben musste
für mich persönlich steht das tier wohl
immer im vordergrund und ich denke auch
außerhalb des des tirols sind themen wie
co2 ausstoß wasserverbrauch
landverbrauch zentral und und über hier
setzen wir an und freuen uns dass wir
eben heute durch dieses event raucht
unserem ziel einen schritt näher
gekommen sind am anfang stehen ein paar
stammzellen von einer kuh etwa dann
werden diese zellen dazu gebracht dass
sie sich in einer nährflüssigkeit teilen
und vermehren und am ende zur bibel
verbinden rund 70 firmen weltweit
forschen und entwickeln dieses labor
fleisch bzw
gezüchtete fleisch die firma moser mit
aus holland bereits seit acht jahren es
rückt immer näher
sein motto kampen ist mittlerweile haben
einige unternehmen gute verfahren und
gute produktionsanlagen entwickelt ich
denke es wird in den nächsten paar
jahren nun wirklich losgehen zuerst nur
in kleinen mengen zu hohen preisen aber
kühlen sie nummer einfach sehr
ineffizient deshalb glauben wir dass
langfristig das gezüchtete fleisch
billiger werden wird als herkömmliches
fleisch aber ein schritt nach dem
nächsten
eine hürde ist in singapur schon
genommen vor zehn monaten genehmigten
die dortigen behörden den verzehr von im
labor gezüchteten fleisch in der eu
könnte es in anderthalb bis drei jahren
soweit sein so lange dauert die
zulassung dann steht der revolution
nichts mehr im wege ist die szene
überzeugt
sondern identisches produkt mit gleichen
geschmack gleicher konsistenz günstiger
mit weniger umweltbelastungen ohne
tierleid haben kann warum sollte man da
noch sagen ich will mein fleisch aber
von einem toten tier es gibt dann keinen
grund mehr in
drei jahren schätzt david brandes wird
es ihre fleischbällchen auf dem markt
geben hühnchenfleisch aus dem labor für
das keine federn gelassen hat
also guten appetit sage ich jetzt mal
noch nicht aber guten abend noch und bis
9 aber um 0.45 meldet sich anna maria
schuck mit unserem heutigen update darin
auch ein bericht von fußball-länderspiel
gegen nord mazedonien 1 4 0 sieg für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft
[Musik]
guten abend noch immer ist das tief
christian unterwegs wird sich morgen
weiter richtung osten verziehen und sich
dann über der türkei wirklich auflösen
zwischen dem hoch oldenburg ii und dem
tief in kommt bei uns recht kühle luft
haben und die breitet sich von
skandinavien bis zu den alpen aus und so
liegen morgen schon die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen skandinavien
und dem alpenrand bei 5 bis 10 grad wer
jetzt mitte oktober noch sommer sucht
der wird allenfalls auf den kanarischen
inseln im süden der iberischen halbinsel
oder auch am östlichen mittelmeer fündig
heute nacht fällt etwas regen südlich
der donau und sonst sind einige schauer
unterwegs im westen findet sich auch mal
nebel unter diesen vielen wolken bleibt
die nacht recht mild die temperaturen
sinken auf 10 bis 3 grad und morgen über
tage ist es dann eher kühl mit werten um
die 10 grad am kühlsten burton in
östlichen mittelgebirge und an den alpen
am mildesten wird sie am niederrhein mit
14 grad der regen der nacht zieht weiter
nach süden und so kann sich morgen hier
zwischen weser und elbe aber auch in
schleswig-holstein schon mal die sonne
zeigen an der ostsee sind einzelne
gewitter möglich weiter richtung süden
regnet es zum teil richtig kräftig eine
kleine ausnahme gibt es diesem streifen
zwischen der donau und im schwarzwald da
könnte es auch mal trocken bleiben am
alpenrand stauen sich die wolken und
oberhalb von 1300 meter fällt auch
schnee mit schnee haben wir es auch noch
am mittwoch zu tun aber danach das milde
und besonders im süden noch sonniger
guten abend